hey guys I am here with actor and
activist and author and environmentalist
you have one more for me before I say
your name
that's a puppeteer puppeteer Ed Begley
Jr I did not know the puppeteer not of
course here I just wanted to embellish
my resume that was that was pretty good
a thing to do nowadays just Pat it a
little bit are you guys of course no and
from a zillion movies and TV shows but
what your real passions are I think your
real passions are really the environment
right even more than acting although
you've done a tremendous amount I have a
great deal of passion for acting but the
urgency is such that I have a lot of
zeal for environmental work now now more
than ever I started 1970 but now more
than ever so much of the stuff that
you've dedicated your life to so in line
with what we do here at riot which is
why I've been harassing you on Twitter
for about two hours to get in here about
a time and you came in so what I want to
start with is environmental studies now
cool but you were doing this stuff 30
years ago if not longer 45 works are 45
years ago so start there how did you get
into it and what possessed you to be
doing this when it wasn't cool cuz
everybody's doing it now right it was
very uncool to drive a three wheel
electric vehicle back in 1970 I can
promise you it was not a babe magnet
yeah I took Cindy Williams on a date the
one who played Shirley is over I'm
Shirley until they're in a date and my
electric field I'll pick you up my
electric car I first thought it was kind
of cool but I don't think I had fully
charged it or something right I was
going kind of slow there's a kid going
past us on hot wheels given it's a
finger not but how did you actually get
an electric car back then so you built
this yourself for now I bought it from a
guy named Dutch and I just looked up in
the yellow pages when I'm gonna just so
I can tell people I tried I'm gonna look
up under electric cars or electric
vehicles to see that they don't have
them I know nobody what the hell is this
electric cars I got told them they were
really they were really supposed to be
for like retirement communities they had
a California license plate but it was
basically a golf cart with an enclosure
you know like a and it was it was fully
legal I mean it was real Eagle I quickly
surmised it was much cheaper to plug it
in the wall than it was to buy 1970
gasoline same way my electric car my
Nissan Leaf is the same today it's
cheaper to plug it that into the wall
yeah than to buy 2015 gasoline just
cheaper so I like that and there was no
maintenance to speak of no tune-up or
oil change a fan belt radiator flush
smog check valve job none of that
anymore so I went I like this green
stuff but what really led me to it
before that electric car was living in
smoggy LA my dad was a very positive
person he was a a conservator light to
conserve he turned off the lights and
turned off the water save string and
save tinfoil so he was the son of Irish
immigrants he lived through the Great
Depression so he died within a few days
of the first Earth Day David and so I
did a lot of this stuff to honor him as
much as anything yeah so when you
started doing this did people think you
were nuts because right even now I'll
see some weird vehicle on the road yeah
that somebody's makeshift put together
I'm not talking about the leaf where the
Volt right some other thing it would be
like well what's that person they musta
thought you were bonkers I the electric
car was nutty but all the other stuff
people right away went that's good I
want to do that recycling in 1970 yeah
was quite cumbersome you had to drive it
to my electric car thankfully I would
drive it to you know like Sun Valley
only on Saturdays and Sundays between
12:00 and 3:00 could you recycle
anything glass aluminum anything a
newspaper so I took all that stuff they
are starting a 1970s started composting
and composting back then I was in
apartment so I couldn't have a compost
pile I had like a little you know diaper
pail with a lid on it you know and I put
all the table scraps in that and I would
take it what am I gonna do with I saved
it now I didn't think it through what I
do with it now an apartment I you know
the railroad tracks there's some land
there nobody would probably bothered me
and I started going the dead of night
I'd dig a hole and put this stuff just
to return it to the earth they kind of
you know and suddenly stuff was growing
there where I was burying this stuff and
it was kind of a great lesson because
stuff just started growing from just
burying organic matter in the ground
incredible and and we still don't really
do that that much right we should wait
more composting programs so just as an
easy thing we're to get more to that
kind of stuff later yeah anybody has any
piece of property with a front or back
yard grow some food you know growing
lawns there's kind of some rich feudal
lord left over or something but you
should grow some food that you can eat
and then also don't be trucking in
organic matter to amend the plants with
you know plant food make your own plant
food from your old table scraps and
grass clippings or whatever you got as
far as the drought that seems to be what
everybody's talking
now ironically I don't know if people
can see but you have a couple of drips
on you cuz it is actually oh my god yes
it is it's not sweat it's not flop sweat
but it's raining and plants are actually
excited and we are in the midst of well
tell us a little bit about the drought
because we've done some stories on it
it's bad I mean it's a very bad drought
there's been very few years in the long
history of measuring law measuring water
in LA and worse than this we had a year
that was three and a half inches about
nineteen twenty something I think I look
back the history of LA rainfall this
past year has been seven and a half
inches before what we just got today
mm-hmm when I hear the news tonight
we'll know what it is maybe seven
three-quarter or eight inches that's a
very bad year yeah average normal is 15
or 16 inches so we have to do something
we've been wasting water by washing our
cars out in the driveway well guilty of
it yeah everybody growing these lush
lawns or what have you in a
Mediterranean ecosystem you know a
semi-arid grassland is what this is
technically and it is very dry here the
only reason la has survived and out all
these lawns and all these this
prosperity is because we got our straw
dipped in somebody else's drink a lot of
the people along the Colorado River like
maybe oh let's say Colorado we'd like to
you know hold on to some of that water
and in Arizona what have you everybody
wants a piece of it and then the other
one is the California Aqueduct that
takes water from the San Joaquin Delta
so those three legs to the stool of the
only thing that keeps us from falling
over and if one of them gets a little
wobbly we're gonna have real trouble do
you think people actually understand the
severity of this no because I just read
a story this week that ethos which is
the company that Starbucks yes bottled
water from they're moving out of
California because there's not enough
water here good for them what do we have
to do to actually get people to wake up
because you know it's one of those
things where it's like it happens so
slowly that people don't really realize
or they think well my lawns all right
I'll still keep going right what what do
you do to kind of really slap people in
the face with this I don't know that you
can do any more than every water agency
every news broadcast practically
everybody every newspaper is doing the
illusion is this right here hey I want
some water here we go hmm it's available
you turn on the tap and it comes out so
we think it's all going to last forever
yeah we're near the end we're heading
towards a cliff now because what has
recharged the aquifers that they're
going deeper and deeper with
water bottling plants and agriculture
the the solution the problem would just
go deeper and deeper
that's our bank account your draining
your bank account to nothing you get a
paycheck at some point to replenish that
bank account there's no pay day now
because there's no Sierra snowpack
that's what we're up against and people
I'm afraid I kept if we'd had this
conversation a month ago no we're gonna
get to them we're gonna let them know
somehow and maybe we are but I don't
know what it's gonna take you can't let
people know anymore there's people in my
neighborhood that still have these lush
lawns so sprinklers are on in the rain
in the rain you come and you see the
sprinklers on which now is a violation
and it should be so I've been seeing
these stories pop up on Gawker and some
of these sites we're there now they're
trying to publicly shame some of these
people you know they listed a bunch of
celebrities with big lush lawns but
isn't that just a tiny portion of it
isn't this real like the real usage is
really from probably industrial stuff
right and golf courses and things like
that like the residential stuff even
though I guess it gets headlines isn't
that everybody's gonna come to the party
residential as part of it but you're
right it's much smaller the notion of
growing rice and almonds on the western
side the San Joaquin Valley is just I
think it's just foolhardy we had the
illusion that it was gonna be okay for
yours because we had excess all these
people that say I've got a ticket in
line for my water it's a law you can't
take it from me I'm an almond grower I
grow rice I grow broccoli I grow it up
the people that grow broccoli and
lettuce can go well okay I'm not getting
my allotment the way I used to I'll
leave it fallow for a year and get a
fade state of federal tax credit for
doing the good thing but what do you do
with a nama tree you can't leave it
fallow these people have their ticket in
line all of these tickets in line for
water in California are based on excess
nearly all of them yeah there's very few
that aren't based on excess from the San
Joaquin Delta
there's been no excess for years it's
this illusion that people in residential
neighborhoods people in agriculture
everybody thinks because they somehow
turn on a tap and comes down magically
kind they point the finger at you know
they did finger at environmentalists
been doing like causing this like we're
the ones doing it that's like blaming
the smoke detector company for the fire
yeah you know we didn't start this fire
we're just trying to save whatever
species we can the San Joaquin you know
in the San Francisco Bay Delta certain
species of fish are like Canaries in the
all mine that's for all of us you can't
dry up all the water you can't suck a
triangle how did that happen you know we
know we can see it coming what's the
silver lining here is it that technology
is gonna save us is it gonna be we're
gonna start rebuilding desalinization
plants is it that is it that the
conservation will work or have we
crossed that threshold where even if we
cut back we're still behind the eight
ball what the final Desalle should be
the last thing on your list that's when
you're really people are you know
standing in line like you know Blade
Runner kind of life you know people are
in real trouble dying thirst and
what-have-you
so is it not efficient that's where
people write it takes a lot of energy to
mass amount of energy you know how
people go all you got left is table saw
that's salt it's not quite table salt
where do you put it you can't really
easily and reintroduce it in the marine
environment without hurting a lot of
species you know because it's such a
concentration of salt and other minerals
so there's a problem with that and
there's a lot of energy but there's much
cheaper ways let's just follow the money
and the economy of it if we collected
our rainwater really collected
efficiently in two important ways people
doing it the way I did it for years poor
man's rainwater capture sawed off with a
hacksaw your downspout put a barrel
under it put it up on some block so you
can get to the spigot at the bottom and
you're gonna collect your rainwater for
like 80 bucks a barrel or whatever they
charge for them now you can get them
online and I think they're 80 bucks for
a barrel there's something like that
there are discount ones where people
recycle old olive oil barrels or
something and get those even cheaper so
do that number one number two people
have more resources which I do on
building a LEED Platinum all might have
put a ten thousand gallon rainwater tank
on the ground ten thousand gallons that
will surely take care of all my
irrigation needs from the last rain in
May to the first rain in October that's
the other one and the most important one
to break up a lot of the way we've
concrete ties you know we've paved over
places like la more permeable surfaces
so the water can go down to the water
table well that's exactly where I wanted
to end the conversation about the
drought because that is exactly what we
do here we try to let you guys know that
you can do something with the news so
not only the government's doing things
but there's things that you yourself can
do anyway what do you think is the is
the drought as bad as it seems are you
doing anything let us know in the
comments right down below so one of the
things we talked
on my show all the time is our food
sources here in America you know all the
subsidies core and all that stuff I was
watching an interview that you did and
you were talking about just a
plant-based diet and how it can affect
our bodies and our minds and the economy
and all this stuff so I thought it was
an interesting place to jump off with
you on this is how important is food in
general to the environment just the
stuff that we take in how important is
that to the bigger environmental picture
there's a friend of mine he was a cattle
rancher a feedlot operator and he says
that the fork is one of the most
dangerous weapons we've ever held in our
hand and I think there's some truth to
that again I don't want to dictate to
anybody what they eat my wife eats meat
and I don't really give her a hard time
about it she eats it rarely but she does
on occasion yeah it's a fair amount of
chicken and fish and what-have-you
things like that I'm a vegan myself
because I think it's good for me I
really feel very good when I eat a
plant-based diet and it's certainly good
for the ecosystem it just takes so much
more water and land and energy to grow a
pound of beef and it does a pound of
broccoli yeah so that's something we
have to consider even for the meat
eaters to eat as I suppose my wife does
you know just a few times a year or a
few times a month if you're a big meteor
just cut down a bit and see if you can
live with that see how you like it and
there's other substitutes now you know
in the old days that was what we had to
do to survive it's a different world now
you can be up in Fairbanks as you know
you can get veggie dogs and broccoli in
the middle of winter you know it's just
a different world that we live in yeah
and so I think a plant-based diet is a
very good way to go and certainly when
you're growing yourself it's quite
economical you can make very cheap
vegetables if you do it that way if not
if you buy and lots of you know plant
amendments that are expensive and water
tap water with coming from a leader you
know you can wind up with $8 tomatoes if
you're not careful
very sure oh how much is it is that
we're just hugely separated from our
food sources you know they do all these
studies there is something like the
average chicken that you might get a
Trader Joe's came from 2,000 miles away
or something crazy where only a hundred
years ago you pretty much lived in a
village or pretty much close by where
you were
your food from it comes such great
distances now people just want their
damn grapes in the middle of winter they
come from Chile of course you know they
want different things
you can do that but it comes at great
cost I try to eat seasonally as best I
can
you know nobody's perfect but I go to
the farmers market there in Studio City
yeah to supplement what I can't grow
myself but I've been growing food since
I've had my very first home in 1979
before that of his apartment renter you
know and I couldn't I couldn't grow food
back then they didn't have community
gardens the way they do now now if you
don't have if you an apartment you don't
have a piece of dirt your front or
backyard you can get part of a community
garden if they don't have one you can
start one yeah there's a lot of that
available but I've shown my kids who are
now 36 and 37 who both are master
gardeners I've shown them where food
comes from it doesn't come from the
Ralphs tree the Safeway Bush it comes
from soil and water and sunshine and
that's how you make food what do you
think about the the other part of it not
just the stuff that you're putting in
your system to stay alive but sort of
the therapeutic part of it because I
have an apartment but I have a little
little front area where I grow some n
tomatoes and some mint and you know a
bunch of herbs and things like that and
I find just clipping the stuff I
actually find it calms me down it gets
me away from my phone and all the
electronics and I feel like that's an
important piece of it too just for your
mental state as a human you know you're
connecting here into the big one now I
know I myself have one of these smart
device I'm looking at hey man there's a
great website for Yosemite we got a look
at this website for Yellowstone it put
the thing away put in your pocket turn
off get to Yosemite Yellowstone if not
if you're not inclined to do that you
have time just get out to your garden
and you don't have a garden you get part
of a community garden is you're
suggesting if you get your hands in the
dirt it's the ultimate therapy you feel
connected again to what our real riches
are I think I get my paycheck from Sony
Pictures or from Warner Brothers II
Universal Studios that's not where I get
my real paycheck from that's right buy a
bunch of stuff stuff like Home Shopping
Network stuff and some stuff perhaps a
little more important than that but
mostly mostly I'm buying stuff with the
money that I make at my suppose a job my
real income I think is from the soil and
the water and the sunshine to grow food
and be part of that system that's what
we really need
clean water clean air and food and
that's our real well that's our real
paycheck yeah now you're not telling
Sony that it would be ok to pay you in
composting right it was a nice sentiment
III yeah I think I may have misspoke you
may have spoken there so one of the most
interesting things I think about this is
how businesses are finally coming around
so you were on the front end of doing
this personally and I see a lot of
people doing that now but actually
businesses are becoming green and
they're becoming aware that people want
this are there how do you when you're
shopping and you know not just for food
but for whatever how do you sort of
mitigate figuring out what's doing good
work what companies are being
responsible and all that
well you guys are deep into that into
rewarding good companies and good
behavior and I think that's great
riot that they're doing that and
something I've been interested in for
years a lot of businesses have figured
out what we started to see at the late
80s or early 90s there was a company
called northern telecom Nortel northern
telecom they made more than half the
switching equipment back then for AT&T
and part of their process to clean their
circuit boards they use CFCs but the
head of the company back then in 1989
whatever started to hear about ozone
depletion went from the top on down all
my middle management people all the top
executives like me down the janitor
we're gonna find some way to stop using
CFCs and we're gonna do that because
it's the right thing to to do I don't
care what it cost I'll take a haircut
with my salary yeah I said and amend it
they found there was a way to do with
citrus to clean the circuit boards with
citrus or something or some other
substance and they the circuit boards
work just fine they didn't have a
diminished product because of it and he
met with the CFO after a year or so
doing he said tell me the bad news now
that I've mouthed off and done this how
much is this cost us we saved $250,000
yeah well that was a kind of a wake up
call late 80s Early 90s good wait a
minute they did the right thing and they
save money there's lots of that out
there occasionally people are doing it
and it cost them that happens on
occasion
sometimes its revenue neutral but the
vast majority of the time that I've seen
that people did the right thing
certainly with new buildings when
businesses are moving into remodeling or
building a new building they realize the
savings nowadays because building a new
building or even a house as I'm doing
a LEED Platinum home it's like an
iceberg the kind of iceberg where
there's a little tiny piece above the
water just a little triangle above the
water the vast amount of that iceberg is
below the water that's the cost of
running the building over time over its
many many years of use that little piece
at the top is a cost to building it
that's a little chunk it looks massive
at the time right you're standing on it
there you know waiting for rescue it
looks really big that number that it
cost to do a remodel or to build from
the ground up but over the life of it
it's it's a huge number and people who
are in it for the long haul and many
businesses are looking long-term they
used to just look at the the quarterly
dividend but what's the quarterly number
I don't want to get fired I don't want
the board to get on my ass what can I do
to show a good quarterly return they're
looking beyond that and telling the
board we got to be good corporate
citizens and for the long-term health of
this company because guess what I'm
having a psychic moment now energy
prices are gonna go out you know and
they're still gonna go out they're still
gonna go out just buying some
energy-efficient lighting and an
energy-saving thermostat for your
mom-and-pop store and some weather
stripping or little stuff you're gonna
get a payback on that stuff right away
so I know a lot of people will say and I
think you're addressing this already but
a lot of people say well it's easy it's
easy for you and you've got more money
you can do it but you're saying there
are ways to do this and haven't they
shown that when companies do some of
these changes people are willing to pay
a little bit more that that social
responsibility has become part of all
these business plans right many people
are with many companies you have to do
this stuff because of you know it's it's
the right thing to do III really think
and the return is there people are gonna
feel good about it over time people are
going to understand and when people say
to me the most important point I want to
make is when people say to me ed I can't
afford a Nissan Leaf like you have today
I can't afford you know solar panels
like you have a six kilowatt system and
I say neither could I when I started
when I started in 1970 it was very
expensive to buy solar panels so I
didn't do that took me 20 years to buy
solar electric two decades but I did the
cheap and easy stuff and I say money the
electric car I bought 1970 was not
expensive like a Nissan Leaf or a Tesla
I couldn't afford a Tesla today but I
could afford a leaf Tesla's pretty cool
though it's a very hearty
if I get another series or something I'm
buying one but people who say they can't
do it the way I do it
agreed I couldn't either when I started
you don't run up Mount Everest you get
the base camp and you get acclimated and
adjust and you see how high you can
climb some people aren't going to make
it to the summit some people are never
gonna be able to afford solar electric
but can you buy some light bulbs to
lower your energy bill put money in
their pocket right away mm-hmm you know
energy-saving thermostat weather
stripping bike riding when weather and
fitness permit public transportation to
Defense avail available near you home
gardening home composting all that stuff
is dirt cheap do that stuff and you're
going to see money back right away
all right so naturally I have to talk
about climate change with you you're a
big denier am I mistaken maybe I'll
switch over that may be a big payday in
that I really cash out yeah let's get
some headlines here all right so climate
change I can't believe that in 2015
still when you watch cable news and
whatever they're talking about climate
change they still bring on two people to
debate it as if it's a debate you know
it's not a debate the scientific
community give me a percentage here what
is it something like 91% of science in
97 percentage the number that I've heard
okay so 97% I'm not a mathematician but
that's a pretty high percentage yet they
still have these people debating what
what do you think's going on there we'll
talk about the media part in a sec but
just in terms of how people can deny
something that science is consistently
proving there's a lack of understanding
there's people just dug in
there's several lawmakers I think don't
believe it anymore who still say that
there are deniers but they're really not
but we just don't know how to break them
out of jail together yeah break them out
one at a time they'll be shocked by the
prison guard so like they were almost
held hostage by their constituent
holding ostrich burger and their beliefs
that they're dug in they don't know how
to it needs to be a jail break through
you break all seven or nine of them out
together so now we got to figure out how
to get them all out so they can just you
know there'd be safety in numbers if you
could do that yeah I don't think they
all believe it and they can't you can't
believe it anymore there's just enough
very good science scientific clues as to
the fact it's not only happening but man
is the number one culprit you add more
co2 to the atmosphere it
warms up the planet has always done that
and we have much more co2 than we've
ever had so to not to deny that that's
happening and have all this stuff about
it you know what's happening on Mars and
all this stuff it's all background noise
yeah it's really good science people say
well Galileo was a rogue and he had a
different theory and he was persecuted
you're persecuting us no Galileo had
science he saw he got a telescope
primitive by today's standards but
looked over the holy Christ there's
ganymedian IO and Callisto and Europa
and they're going around Jupiter I can
see it they're in different positions
they're clearly moving around Jupiter so
I can see Copernicus and Galileo use
science and so to to use that we embrace
this denial at our own peril yeah and
right now whatever we do now it is my
opinion that there will be great damage
done to like the Marshall Islands in
South Florida what have you that's in
the pipeline the time to stop that was
back in the 90s yeah we had taken the
action that was recommended and pleaded
for and begged for the perhaps we could
have done something with that but now
we're 2015 people are still debating it
and they're not willing there's a lot of
money obviously in fossil fuels still
and the people who have interest in
fossil fuels want to squeeze the last
dollar out and people kit themselves I
don't think everybody goes I don't care
that I'm ruining the planet I'm gonna do
this and I don't think a lot of people
even think that I think I've heard some
people are in denial like the alcoholic
and denial yeah I think no I'm not doing
anything with to make climate change
they're wrong about that and I need to
keep people warm and healthy and
what-have-you and transport goods and
services around I'm doing a good thing
and people lie to themselves about stuff
it's like an alcoholic we're all
alcoholics on oil we really are yeah I
saw the alcoholic oohs it's that damn
boss of mine that caused me that problem
he was such a bastard that's why I got
fired and that [ __ ] of a wife the
reason I got a divorce is because and
that cop that was a crazy badge heavy
cop dude it was a cop it was the wife it
was the boss it's never yourself we're
the addicts like that right we want to
deny that it's that it's fossil fuels
that's doing this because it's such a
wonderful thing I ride my bike up Laurel
Canyon to Mulholland regularly
and it takes a lot of work David you
know if you can just do this and get to
the top of Mulholland that's all the
effort I did yeah this not pedaling up
for 20 minutes up at the top of my
wallet this went like that and I get up
to the top of Moho it's like what a
miracle and to floud your fields used to
get the ox and you had animals to help
you with the work and get a knock a team
of oxen and go through the fields and
hang on the thing yourself like this and
it was a lot of work to tell a feel by
hand is tremendous work suddenly they
got these contraptions that will tell it
for you mm-hmm a machine this goes to
what we were talking about how far we
are from our food and how easily we can
get everything and the phones that were
it's all sort of interlaced and sort of
takes the responsibility away from us in
so many ways yeah it's a free lunch that
we thought would go on forever and never
had a price tag you know nobody ever
thought there would be something like
climate change there was a brief a very
brief theory from the scientific
community in the 60s about global
cooling yeah it didn't get much play
because it didn't really make any sense
you know but it lasted about a year or
two all it made was a cover of popular
science magazine it didn't really make
peer-reviewed studies like it has like
global warming has but it lasted a while
people have been in denial about it a
long time and then when James Hansen
started to testify at the guy from NASA
in the 80s a lot of the scientific
community and deep people who were had
embraced the global cooling thing
briefly they were like wait a minute
this makes more sense let me look at the
numbers and they look at the numbers and
one by one they were convinced there's
very few people left who think it's not
happening scientists who think it's not
happening consider it in the medical
community though David you go to a
doctor he says it and you got a problem
you have cancer you got to get chemo or
radiation or something right away thank
you
go to another doctor Edie you have
cancer you have you need chemo radiation
or something some treatment like that
right away I'm gonna go the last three
doctors tell you you're fine you're
gonna go with the last three you're
gonna go with a ninety seven who told
you you need cancer treatment right and
you can't say well I don't believe in
cancer thus it doesn't exist you can say
it well you can peril right you could
say it at your own peril and that's
where we're at now so what would you say
to all the people cuz this is one of the
things I hear a lot from Republicans
they'll say
well America what we put out there now
it's unfair for us to say it's other
countries because we've been through our
Industrial Revolution already right so
we can't tell India too what to do right
now or a lot of you know places in that
part of the world we can't tell them
they have to do it because they're going
through what we did you know you mean
like so that there's a sort of self
incontinence here we have to help those
other countries leapfrog over that old
technology we built our Brooklyn Bridge
and Empire State Building with high
sulfur coal and steel mills you know in
Pittsburgh polluting the air that's what
we did we did that no you don't have to
do that again I remember kind of waking
up to the idea of leapfrogging over old
technology back in the 90s I went to
Australia and in Australia in the 90s
everybody had a cell phone
homeless people had cell phones it was
somehow very cheap there with the way
they put up the repeaters and everything
quickly they had subsidies for him I
don't know what they had it because they
leapfrogged over the whole thing there's
there's such a vast country and they
certainly had phone lines in Australia
but the idea of stringing new lines
everywhere and getting telephone lines
all throughout the outback in every part
of Australia no cell repeaters they leap
frogged over the old technology we have
to help them do that with solar the
people in these poor villages they need
light in their Hut right now because
they're knocking over kerosene lamps and
getting burned and they're carrying
kerosene great distances carrying you
know firewood taking down the last tree
you know carrying firewood great
distances we can help them with solar
panels and solar ovens you leapfrog over
the old technology yeah and now that
doesn't work for everything and places
like China who want to manufacture all
sorts of goods and what-have-you you
have to do other things but they're
realizing the problem now in Beijing
because of the lat the lost productivity
from air pollution there yeah we've done
stories on that town I forget the name
of the town with the smog they looted
yeah it's just beyond imagination and
they're starting to see the unfortunate
side effect of it it's not just that
people were unhappy they're losing
productivity why didn't you show up for
work again today I was in the hospital I
was in the pulmonary clinic yeah I
couldn't breathe
I have emphysema I have cancer I'm dying
of cancer from the pollution that's why
I missed work on
very sorry yeah so maybe that's what
I'll get them because they do love
productivity so eventually if the
productivity really starts going down
maybe that then causes some mood there
please they're putting up plenty of coal
plants I'm not suggesting they aren't
but they're putting up many many more
solar manufacturing plants than we are
yeah they're really doubling down on on
solar as well and wind and we need to
export a lot of our good American
technology for them in a number of ways
clean air issues and and others I think
they can benefit from what we've learned
Hey a little bit of good news today
folks you had a lot of bad news here's
some good news from 1970 to date when I
started this we have four times the cars
in LA millions more people now here
comes the good news we have a fraction
of the smog yeah because we did it we
did that you and I and everybody here in
LA did that David because of catalytic
converters on cars combined cycle gas
turbines spray paint booze all the
things big and small cleaning up the
ports of San Pedro and Long Beach you
know plugging those boats in instead of
having running in the harbor all that
stuff big and small that we did all
worked so we need to export that great
technology to China and India and have
them use it in to clean up the air in
these cities and have them be better
world stewards you know for climate
change so I was watching your web series
on Bailey Street and you are building a
house from ground up this this is
clearly your dream right like this this
project is this the dream project more
than anything else you've ever done is
this no no this has been something
kicking and screaming my wife dragged me
to I lived in this house for 26 years
the house was on a show called living
with that yeah I've been there since 88
I loved it I used to joke but I wasn't
entirely joking that I would be
composted out back yeah you know and
then she kept saying from early on when
we were dating in the 90s you go hey you
need more closet space I don't have any
Road whoa whoa honey okay okay I hear
you you got to find another guy you got
to start dating guys this is not gonna
work
I'm never gonna move from this house
ever read my lips I'm never moving yeah
and so I said that and I meant it 93 94
95 finally by 2010 she had worn me down
we had had three very successful years
for that show living with that and
acting
career was doing good and green product
endorsements so we had the money to do
it she said we've got the money now
please would you consider if I could get
you more solar rooftop space to get more
exposure for your panels if I could get
you a bigger vegetable garden I can get
you more room for a rainwater tank on
the ground would you move then I said
okay if you can find point
abcdefg for this price for F ya then
I'll move ya and the [ __ ] did it and I
found the place then I had a bath your
quote not mine I know yeah it's gonna be
good when we're moved into this house
and happy about it I'll feel very good
about it all because you can only do so
much with a retrofit I'm starting with
an 88 when I bought that home it was a
1936 energy inefficient house there was
no insulation the walls whatsoever I
blew it in no insulation of the attic
but these big recycled denim you know
bats up there did all this stuff one
thing after another I made it as
efficient as you could let me tell you
what you can do with new construction we
can blow incredible insulation in the
walls it's modern foam insulation the
walls are 12 inches thick its passive
solar design so winter time the Sun is
hitting the glass summer time and a
little before a little after no Sun is
hitting the glass incredible Lutron
smart equipment for the lighting control
shades and lighting fixtures incredible
high seer rating heating and air units
variable flow for different zones it's
amazing what you can do with modern
construction and we're doing it all
solar low water use faucets and fixtures
everything that you can do we're doing
it what would you say to the people and
I hear well-known authors say this often
that we've at some point within the next
hundred years we're gonna have to leave
this little planet this little rock that
we're on that has some green and happens
to have the right cosmic mix of stuff
for a life or that we're gonna actually
have to go and that's sort of the point
of humanity that will use it up here and
then we'll move on you can see I watch
on that sci-fi do you also what would
you say about that there's no place that
we can get to and there's a lot of risk
in space of radiation and other things
as well see when they send a man to Mars
which you're probably gonna do soon yeah
you'll see the effects of just getting
fifty seven million miles which is
nothing compared and Mars the idea of
setting up a station there what would
you do on Mars how would you grow
food they're the kind of biosphere
remember that thing buyers favor you
know the idea they were not even
remotely self-sufficient they had a big
natural gas generator there to generate
a fair amount of the power yeah and even
then people got sick and there was all
kinds of problems I think they found out
that someone was coming and going from
that ya know and there was like some
sort of mold or fungus that got in there
in that closed ecosystem yeah it's very
hard the idea of having a spare planet
somewhere is folly I don't think we I
don't think that's gonna do you think
this is this is it this is as good as it
gets for life as we know it we need to
make this as hospitable it has always
been a hospitable planet for us in our
history before we were born millions of
years ago is volcanic and very
inhospitable but as Benny has been in a
sweet spot for a while and we have to
keep it there with our behavior as best
we can on that note you have any last
minute tips I think you've given us some
good stuff here but for the average
person that doesn't even care about this
stuff what are like the two most simple
things that you could tell someone all
right go ahead and try to incorporate
some of this at the root of it just live
simply so others can simply live try to
keep your life as simple as possible
having said that a tip a new tip that I
like to tell people is about something
called vampire power unplug all that
stuff that you don't need when you go to
sleep or leave the house there's a lot
of things that you think you need on all
the time then you don't in fact it's a
short list of things that you need on
like your clock radio your you know
whatever things like that that are going
to be blinking midnight when you come
back you plug those in into a power
strip and leave them alone on the other
power strips you put all those little
transformers little plugs and things put
them in there and one two three perhaps
is all it'll be around your house turn
off those power strips at night when you
leave the house you'll save a tremendous
amount of money
all right well at begley it has been a
pleasure I'm glad we finally got to do
this in person this is better than 140
characters right you're pretty good
question I like it a lot better very
good day yes a lot better I appreciate
that and you guys can check out and show
on Begley Street it is on YouTube we're
gonna annotate to it right around here
it's here somewhere
and of course on Twitter anything else
we should pimp out no that's plenty how
about her
in general earth in general protect your
Protectorate there you go